[La musique]
Je crois que maintenant nous ne devons pas penser
combien nous récupérons et nous devons penser à
Pompéi quel endroit résilient pour
l'excellence comme justement de faire renaître
territoire donc nous espérons que
les gens viennent parce que les gens doivent déménager
dans le Vésuve
il doit y avoir le nouveau tourisme
d'abord italien puis j'espère bientôt
aussi à l'étranger
donc on pense beaucoup au territoire et
à la communauté
nous avons derrière nous heureusement
un ministère qui peut nous aider
[La musique]
en grande partie
le maximum pour une température contrôlée
la sécurité se fait comme ça
le doute sera utile quand il y aura
un débit plus élevé et dans tous les cas le
structure externe des fouilles non
autorise ce type de contrôle dans
moment où nous sommes si peu nombreux il y a un
peu avec le flux de touristes que vous pouvez faire est
à droite, mais après j'ai mes doutes un
sur
[La musique]